- [Voiceover] We're asked
to use the translation tool
to determine the translation that will map
triangle WIN, so this right over here,
onto the other triangle.
So let's see if we can
translate this thing.
So I'm gonna use the translation tool.
So I'm gonna start with the translation.
So it says translate by,
and this is gonna say so
how much do we translate
the x coordinates, and how much
do we translate the y coordinates?
Let's see, if I want to map,
if I want to get point W to correspond
to this point right over here,
which it seems like it should,
I would have to go from x equals two,
to x equals negative five.
So my x would have to decrease by seven,
so let me type that in.
Negative seven,
and then, let's see,
on the y side, and we saw that,
by just typing in negative seven,
here we moved it to the left by seven.
And now, in the y axis,
I need to move it down by, let's see,
one, two, three, four.
So my y coordinates, I
move it down by four.
And let's see.
What happens?
And it looks like I was able
to successfully translate it
by translating x by negative seven,
every point here, every point
on this has been shifted
to the left by seven,
and has been shifted down by four.
And I was able to get onto this triangle.
I was able to, through the translation,
the image is now in kind
of that target triangle
that they asked me to map to,
to translate to.
We got it right.